[Musique]
le costume ne fait pas un homme
c'est ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur du costume qui
compte
c'est l'ingéniosité
et peut-être un cœur ouvert
Je n'ai pas fini mon verre
cette institution sacrée
exerce un pouvoir au-delà de votre imagination
Winston votre frère m'a volé quelque chose de
très important
des gens dangereux
le trouvent parce que si vous ne le faites pas, je ferai
peser sur vous deux le poids de toute cette institution.
Sharon
montre à nos invités la porte,
nous avons fait une grosse erreur, entrez ici,
vous êtes mon frère Frankie,
nous devons frapper en premier
et  J'ai besoin de toute l'aide possible, comment
sommes-nous censés croire qu'un gars en
ascot peut retirer ça de
sa cravate
si nous voulons affronter le
Continental,
tous les monstres de cet hôtel en rechercheront, eh
bien, c'est charmant,
nous avons besoin de
beaucoup d'armes.  des armes
[Musique]
c'est plus que de la vengeance c'est de la
justice
[Musique]
peux-tu creuser,
prenons cette maison
et tout ce qui va avec
et c'est parti